dans ce film, ce qui est excitant, c'est que les
enjeux deviennent de plus en plus élevés, le capitaine
Natasha est un peu déchirée entre les deux
côtés avec une casquette, ils ont vraiment une
relation où elle veut raisonner
avec lui
CW puisque je ne peux pas voir mais elle voit Tony
comme un chemin de  la moindre résistance
oh merde tu ne peux pas bouger qui a dit que
maman à l'ail je t'aime fait m'a dit que je suis
vraiment content d'en faire partie Sharon
Carter elle est un peu plus impertinente et aujourd'hui
ce que tu peux faire un peu de
combat là-dedans c'est  génial ce que
j'aime chez Wanda, c'est l'idée d'être
terrifiée par ses propres capacités c'est
vraiment amusant de jouer avec Juicy nous tient
occupés
tu vas chasser une fois que tu auras une
famille d'accueil en prendre une il y a eu quelques
moments où tu regardes un peu  autour
et je suis en bonne compagnie c'est super
bien
toi